foreign
let's go out to James in h-tone what's
up James how we doing
hey I'm I'm doing good uh super excited
to be on the show I'm excited to have
you man what's up how are you uh well I
just wanted to say first I'm super
honored to be able to talk with such an
intelligent and compassionate guy as you
I'm I'm pumped so everybody in the booth
compassionate they'll go with uh
intelligent they're having a hard time
Computing and Computing that but we'll
take I'll take it I'll take it
um well I uh I'll try not to press us
you to death with my question but uh no
preface me to death what else we got
going on let's do it
so uh I have it written down so I don't
go off too far
um but it's it's a it's a long preface
with a little question so I'm just gonna
read what I got here
it's a lot it's it's a lot uh so uh
Michael uh it says my wife left me and
ran for safety in January of 22 because
of my abusive Behavior Uh I've done well
since she left let me pause you I'm
gonna interrupt you as you read this
okay uh what's your abusive Behavior
uh I was physical and I was emotional
and verbal and
um I was also unaware but I was
financially abusive as well so you were
the worst
like yeah okay 100 I was a five-year-old
yeah every uh in every way possible
absolutely and
um for what it's worth I'm proud to be
for recognizing that fact many many men
are terrible spouses like you were and
they never come to that realization so
good for you
um
let me ask you this oh yeah I'm sure
there is
um
when you say you were physical
were you threatening did you actually
punch her did you push her around paint
me a picture of what physical meant
yeah so uh
I apologize I get emotional no it's okay
um
so uh it escalated over time
but um
I uh
it started with verbal abuse and um it
translated from there into uh
punching walls uh throwing things a lot
of
uh
escalation over time ways that I didn't
behave
that I hadn't recognized since uh late
childhood
and um so
yeah it escalated to uh
shoving her onto the couch one day and
then shoving her to the floor the next
and then uh I would like squeeze her I
would put pressure on her legs because I
didn't want to hit her and um
it would leave bruises
and then um one day probably not one
probably it was about four years into
our marriage
um
it reached a pinnacle and
I uh
I I slapped her in the face and I spit
in her face and I shoved her to the
ground and just pressed my arm into her
leg really hard and uh thankfully that
was the night that she left and ran for
safety
what what happened in that moment that
that
you responded in that way
what had built up to that moment
it was a
a lot of build up uh golly
um
I uh was wanting her to come pick me up
from a walk and she couldn't find me and
so uh
I got mad because she couldn't she
eventually found me but I just wanted to
walk and mind you I was in a deep deep I
had in the last six months prior I'd
spent our entire savings on my marijuana
addiction to try and run away we moved
uh back to my childhood town and we were
trying to adopt nine children and
um it fell through and we were our
marriage in the process fell through and
I was around all of my childhood
triggers and um every day I was just
running away more and more and that day
I was trying to
ah just get outside of myself and in any
way possible and um got home after the
uh Angry walk home when she couldn't
find me and um yeah it just blew up
and didn't know how to control myself in
that moment and uh yeah
so I have to be honest with you
um
guy to guy husband to husband
me being the dad of a six-year-old
little girl
there are some things I want to say
that wouldn't help the situation but it
would make me feel better
I'm sorry I need you to know and on
behalf of everybody listening I'm not
going to say that stuff it's not going
to be helpful to this conversation
because you know right
I I know and many people have told me my
mentor told me and uh yeah I've had lots
of people tell me what you I imagine you
would want to tell me
um it's my wife calls I can feel it
um and she's pointed it out on me
um
she recognized back in college she would
grab my arm and say we need we need to
leave wherever we were like we need to
go right now and I'd be like no I'm fine
and she would say she she eventually
told me she wouldn't tell me my tail
early on but
um she would say my jaw clinches in a
certain way that you're about to get in
a fight you're about to do something
stupid we need to go right now and I can
feel it on me now and so I'm not gonna
start a fight with you I'm not gonna try
to be tough in it because we're just on
a phone call here
um
what I what I want to start this call
with is this or not start this call but
I want to make sure I put this out there
you can be around childhood triggers you
can have some really cool expectations
for your life or some insane ones like
adopting nine kids thank God that fell
through thank God that filter
um
no those nine kids had no business going
to an addict abusive home right
um yeah I don't care how many triggers
you are I don't care which family
members you're around I don't care what
what childhood friends you end up I
don't care any of that crap
you have a choice to make in every
moment of your life right
awesome okay so you were abusive thank
God your wife left she took off on you
as she should have are y'all divorced
I'm proud of her uh it became official
uh
about two weeks ago okay so it took
about a year to go through the whole
process
yeah okay about 11 months okay
all right um so yeah I've uh I've had a
bit of a road to Damascus experience if
you will okay and um I uh I'll I'll try
to stay away from jargony talk but um
you listen to this show yeah be direct
so yeah I mean
what it says here well I'm not gonna
read the script it's uh what what
changes have you made in your life
so many it's overwhelming rip them off
let's go
right so uh I've I'm down since uh since
late February I'm down 130 pounds wow
I and it's not packing back on it's
intentional
um I go on a daily uh three to five mile
walk minimum no not minimum I I I go on
a daily three to five mile walk it
usually takes an hour to an hour and a
half uh I've read a lot of books
um I have gotten sorted out in my moral
values and I've got a mentor who has
poured his entire life into mine
I was able to I I quit my
antidepressants cold turkey uh not
advice I know but uh I was getting ready
to go to a drug rehab facility for a
year uh and I decided I didn't want to
do that I wanted to try and find a
different way and it turned out really
well I've impressed some people but I
don't care about impressing people I
just want to be better
um I have
been able to maintain employment for a
long time
longer than normal I have been like 10
months
yeah that's not a long time but it's
longer than you have in the past right
it's uh largely longer than most any
other job I've had all right we'll go
with that as a win keep going
okay I
started uh going back to school to
finish my bachelor's degree
um
I started my business back up
um that was another thing that led to a
ton of depression uh because I didn't
have my business running and I was just
really futile living an aimless life
um and yeah I so I I've gotten my my
physical health in order I've done well
to get my uh intellectual side going my
my spiritual health is really locked in
the most over anything and I'm just
trying to learn how to uh overcome my
traumas I feel like the world owes me
something and oh well I often want to
believe that the world owes me something
and that I'm entitled uh to uh some help
and I'm not uh I'm not I'm 29. it's not
cute anymore uh good for you there's no
sympathy and I need to grow up and
um My ultimate question here is
I uh and I'm afraid to ask this too
because it's unbiased and I know you
tell the truth
um
I I miss my wife like crazy and um your
ex-wife I uh your ex-wife
uh yeah that uh
so I miss my ex-wife like crazy and
um
um I desired to uh have her uh gave her
back into my life and um my uh
uh that's a big long-term
dream of mine to have her back
um but the big thing here is um
so uh what would it take for me to have
a realistic shot at restoration and
Reconciliation of my marriage and
getting my wife back in my life if
that's ever possible again I'm I'm
committed to her and I'm committed to
whatever it takes to show her I'm
different and a new man I just my
responsibility uh waned and I have not
put in tons of work to overcome my
trauma
um
I'm not going to beat you up for wanting
to get your the woman that you love back
that makes sense to me
that you love her
and cosmically I honestly honestly in my
guts listening to your story don't
believe it's about her I don't think you
liked that guy who you became because
you became a monster
and not the monster you could control
you were an adult you were a child
monster which is the most dangerous kind
and I think you wanna
um uh I think you want to redo that
and I do I think she's the person you
hurt so bad she is the shining example
of who you became when you were at your
worst
and
um you should 100 be in jail and you're
not
I agree right so when you became your
worst she is the poster of that
and so you want to go fix that and make
that right
okay
um so I don't fault you for that not
even a little bit
um
thankfully that's not your choice
yeah
I you've impressed me greatly with the
the work you've done
very very impressive this is a guy that
fell over the like it's like one of
those uh Wiley Coyote cartoons you've
actually fell off the cliff and there
happened to be like a one squirrely tree
growing out of the side of the cliff
that you you know your shirt caught on
before you fell all the way to your
death and you managed to claw and
scratch your way back to the top right
yeah I uh I also added I forgot to
mention that I did
um domestic abuse recovery program I've
been in therapy for the last uh eight or
nine months cool and I've done some
other emotional recovery no I got you I
got you
um so I'm the work you've put in is very
very impressive
very very impressive
all of these things on their own lose it
130 pounds it's it's damn near
impossible
um so choosing to have an hour
committing to an hour exercise program a
day if everyone in the United States did
that
um our country would be healed within 24
months I believe that with all my guts
if people just start walking and
exercising and waving to each other
um
reading is hard getting a mentor is hard
emotional recovery work is hard you've
done that you have not done the thing
that will take you a long time to do and
in fact you've circled it and avoided it
in a really masterful way
abusive people
and you you touched on it
are entitled
right that's that's that's the
foundation the world owes me you owe me
which is another way of saying you are
mine possessive right that you can do
all of the physical healing you want you
can do all the emotional and quote
unquote psychological healing you want
you can go get a anger management
certificate you can do all that stuff
it's all good it's all fine
but you have done zero
work relationally
I agree you don't know how to be in a
relationship
in relationships are the things that set
you off
somewhere along the way childhood trauma
is my guess is relationships were so
weaponized
there was such a point of fear and
anxiety and Terror for your little body
that it is unable to at this moment and
it can learn there is healing here
um but it's unable to be in them
because my guess is if you're if you're
a a mentor pushed you really hard you'd
eventually break that off
he's uh he's uh not giving up on me uh I
know I know but you're giving up on him
yeah there you go you've tried right
I uh I I met him through my church and
um in my church there are um uh it's my
biggest struggle uh I I am tempted to
say that I feel lonely often uh my my
relationships uh suffer I don't I don't
have a ton of uh I I have my gang of
guys that I can go to and tell them
anything but uh I don't have yeah
relationships it's my big struggle for
sure
and that your gang of guys that you can
tell quote unquote anything to
let me be real clear
my gang that's like that
Trevor and Michael and Craig and Kevin
and Todd
John
if I called them and told them that I
was up for a walk and I asked them to
come my wife to come pick me up and she
couldn't find me to the point that I
choked her and shoved her to the ground
and injured her
brother God help me
foreign
yeah so I'm calling BS on these guys you
can tell everything to
I didn't have them prior okay so you are
practicing being in relationship here's
what I'm telling you number one doing
all of this work with a goal to get back
with an ex-wife who you are highly
abusive to
is not the point
because all of his hinges on something
that's out of your control
which is her choosing somewhat
psychopathologically
to get back into a relationship with a
guy that's physically and emotionally
and psychologically assaulted her over a
long period of time
okay you have to do this because you're
worth being well and stopping this
madness from taking another inch of your
family tree
and you still don't believe you're worth
all of this
you don't
some days I do but uh not not uh largely
no yes the internal narrative is you
know I'm a piece of crap and yeah I need
to give up because uh it's been long
enough and no nothing good has come from
it well good things have come from it
but not what you want so just go ahead
and do that incredible things have come
from this
but not that core which is the world
owes me
and you nailed it the world owes us
nothing we all leave this thing in a box
right
all of us do
and so until you switch the dial from
I'm doing all this stuff and dude you've
done hard hard things I'm doing this so
that I can get like I can get my trophy
back dude I'm telling you right now this
ends in Ash
if you do this because James from
Houston is worth going to bed at night
without any meds
James is worth sitting around with a
bunch of guys laughing James is worth
getting upset and having a set of uh
Tools in this tool kit to not rage out
on his poor wife who just was trying to
find him and he gave bad directions
or she sucks at reading the map who
cares right
until you believe that all of this is
you just extra I mean this is just a
long exercise in white knuckling
okay
Tomatoes like
it feels like uh a never-ending striving
you know why because you're still trying
to achieve love and you've been doing
this since you were six stop
you cannot achieve love my friend
you have to receive it
and receiving means opening your hands
and opening your hands means
vulnerability and vulnerability means
somebody may hurt you real real bad and
instead of allowing that to happen you
hurt them first
and until you flip that over my friend
you're going to be in a steady Loop
deloop d loop-de-loop d loop-de-loop of
look what I did now look what I did now
look what I did now look what I did now
and that core
rage underneath is going to keep burning
and burning and burning and running and
running and running and running
um I I'm I'm stunned that I'm saying
this
I'm really proud of you you've worked
really hard
and for you to say it's all amounted to
nothing is dishonest that's a lie it's
amounted to a lot
you lost 130 pounds you've changed your
entire physical physiological being
you started practicing relationships
subjecting yourself to hard stuff
what I'm suggesting is
it's time to put all of this work into
the relationship side
because you're not telling that group of
guys everything you're not
you haven't told them
um you don't tell them all the good
stuff you don't tell them all the bad
stuff and more importantly you don't
tell them what happened to you when
you're a kid
grief demands a witness the things that
happen to you you're gonna have to look
somebody and say them out loud
somebody that could use them against you
and then they don't
and your body relaxes and breathes
because it's safe for the first time in
a long long long time
and that sense of safety that sense of
that allows other people to enter into
your space further and deeper and that's
intimacy that's relationship that's love
so you man you're on the right path
you've made a turn that very very few
men make and I'm proud of you
but getting your wife back can't be the
goal here because you can't control what
she decides to do with her life
all you can control is you
and hear me say this and if you're
watching this I'm looking directly at
the camera you're worth this
do this for you
do this for your many use am I in I the
little James's that come down the road
they're going to be born one day
so that them and their spouses never
experience this
learn relationship and learn love
and maybe your wife will call you back
or you actually have to call you back
one day probably not Maybe
but that's not the goal loving you is